today's topic uh so there's a clip on
espn i want to show everyone which is
basically a discussion around
uh women's basketball and basically
there's the number one overall pick
having a discussion with tracy mcgrady
who is a hall of famer
uh and one of the greatest basketball
players who've ever played so the
clipping question went viral
i got a question and this is not a shot
at
women uh in in basketball well good
because you're gonna be like
no i had this talk i think man rebecca
lobo had this talk uh during the hall of
fame and i was talking about
um doing something that gets you know
not your average fans people that don't
watch wnba basketball
what can we do to get those fans to tune
in and i was like
why can't we lower the goal to at least
nine nine and a half feet
because i think for somebody that don't
watch wnba basketball
to have women dunking on other women
would definitely bring more excitement
to that game
she's already done listening yeah she's
already like she's like all right i
already know
yeah yeah yeah go finish your scent no
because she knows she's already she's
ready to retaliate
but it's not enough for your information
uh the net i think it's like 12 feet
how tall is it it's 10 it's 10 it's not
12 it's 10 10. okay so it's 10
and yeah so it's 10 feet and essentially
he wants it lowered a little bit because
he wants
um there to be more dunking which he
thinks would create more excitement and
therefore draw more fans as you as you
may know
the wnba's financials are actually
really terrible uh they're basically
subsidized by the nba so it's a it's
it's a
say it i don't know i don't have a good
word for it but uh
how do we say this respectfully it's a
leech league
all right uh but it is i mean the nba is
providing all that
is what it is okay so how do we get more
seats how do we create more of a fan
base so that therefore the athletes can
get paid
so his suggestion lower the net more
dunking so let's hear her response
you know those guys that don't watch wma
basketball
tune in and you get more fans that way
what do you think about that
i mean my my thought on it is you know
i've been playing basketball on a
10-foot hoop my whole life
so to move it to nine and a half it's
gonna take a long time to get used to
that
and then also like we're only playing
basketball to dunk like i'm not sure
no you playing you don't i don't you
just want to see me dunk on somebody
i don't know he caught himself because
of how bad it would sound
what yo i would love to see you dangling
somebody
you can switch gears with me anytime
throw back lavar can i switch gears with
you for because i have a question here
switch gears with me anytime when you
got kicked from yes
yeah you know what i mean so it's just
but
i understand what she's saying when she
says
it will take a long ass time to adjust
to adjust it will take a time
of course so what do we play do we play
basketball to dunk
do you eat chicken for the spice no you
just spice is something that you add on
it
to add some spice to make it spicy
to to put it up a bit you know you add
spices to
add some to the flavor we don't watch
basketball
just for the dunk but the dunk is the
spice and it has
when you when it's done properly and
here and there you have the dunk it's
just oh
okay guess what guess what when your
chicken's not selling wet well
you got to do something different you
got to add something you can't just sell
the same old chicken but well this is
what i'm used to making
that's called a failing business you
gotta improve your business
you gotta but you're so stubborn and you
wanna be like i can do things just as
well as men can
it's just because you can or some of you
can doesn't mean that most of you can't
and if we're talking about the product
the wnba is not nearly
as good as the nba it's exciting it's
not even good as
college basketball it's not and it
reflects your numbers so if you want to
win you have to be
shrewd business person there are female
sports
that despite the level athleticism being
inferior to men
still do just as well take tennis
the women in tennis cannot stand up to
the men in tennis yeah but it's not the
same thing you understand
no they could not send the same thing
they did the demand in tennis but
they're playing women
so what's the difference well the
difference is the ball doesn't
the weight of the ball doesn't affect
them the weight of the
tennis racket doesn't affect the play
you know what i mean
whereas the who might am i if you don't
jump
as as
high and it's lit it's gonna be less
spectacular of course it is it's gonna
add less spice to it the woman playing
tennis
it's spicy it's you know what it is
though to the regular eye
the difference between the men's tennis
and the women's tennis is not as
glaring as it is to the athletes who
play whereas
when you watch the wnba and you watch
the nba it's like watch
watching w feels like you're watching
the nba in slow motion yes
with less technique yes so that's why
for me i'm like guys you have
a clear glaring difference in the
quality of product of course everyone's
going to go here
your product doesn't even look close to
it you just have to ask so you need to
get creative
and i don't think there's anything wrong
you know there's nothing wrong with
lowering the basketball
because it the the net sorry yeah in i'm
not a basketball player
but i've played well i've been doing
track and field a
big part of my life and in track and
field everything on the woman's side
everything is different
when you do shot put though the weight
is different when you do
uh pole vault the the bar is is lower
when you do hurdles
the hurdles are lower but it makes it as
exciting
as it's it's watching a woman do hurdles
and men do hurdles
it's exciting you don't even notice that
the hurdles
are lower you just see the power the
strength
yes the number at the end is going to be
a little bit higher but
used in terms of the performance and how
it's executed
it's it's it's the form is better
if it's the same form a look man going
over
hurdles is the same foreign the form
that women have when they go over
hurdles
yes so acknowledging acknowledging the
differences between males and females
and adjusting
is not sexism it's realism biology
yo we need there you go yeah we need to
acknowledge those differences
it makes it makes for a better product
so
i don't i feel like she's being stubborn
and she's not taking the time to listen
instead she's being defensive but like
you're a professional your job is to
play like a professional
and to generate money for the league and
if the league is not generating money
you as a professionals have to say what
can we collectively do
to get people to pay money so that we
can continue getting paid
that's how i feel hold on hold on what
is it
what is what's her name brianna stewart
brianna mr stewart
ma'am what is it you want
you want equal pay you want the same pay
as the nba
or you want to play the same game
i don't believe that you can do both
because it's not as exciting if you want
to have a better pay you're going to
need to spice things up in order to
attract more money you know i hate that
i hate that what he said
is somehow a contentious topic that
because we don't want to appear
just or whatever that we can't even
suggest things that would make women
sports better
from a male perspective what if he had
to make the suggestion more acceptable
like the idea that you can't look at an
idea at face value and try to ingest it
to me is what sucks about this
conversation
like everyone's walking on eggshells
whoa okay so
um yeah uh yeah so
the um yeah uh take all of that off
and actually talk
and you'll it'll it'll you'll be able to
have a better conversation i hate it
in other sports we see it yeah the
weights are different the
things are lower the nets are smaller
some it's it's
it's making this the sport more exciting
someone said i would dead ass rather
find a five dollar bill than a free wnba
ticket on the crowd
oh man that's a rough comment it's rough
but it's true
i actually felt the same way when i'm
telling him and it's just it's not the
same appeal
you have to i feel the same way about uh
cfl canadian football league yes it's
like you want
you cannot pay the same money the cfl is
you cannot pay the same
money the players from the cfl are
making than the people from the nfl you
can't they can't have the same
because it's not the same game first
the players are in failure the players
are inferior
the ball is different size the the the
the the
the feel it is a different size
everything is different size everything
is different
it's not even the same cfl and nfl is
not even the same game
i went to a cfl game it was unwatchable
i've yeah i've been to a couple hours
that were watchable but still
there's some that are just like you have
to pay me to go
that's how bad i thought this was but
you know what the cfl in terms of
profits
isn't the greatest organization in the
world it's not
and so someone came to them with
suggestions they would be in their best
interest to take them in and maybe
adjust
but that's just me but anyways that's
all i have but that
that's pretty much it in other sports
and a lot of other sports
to make it more interesting
there is a difference between men and
women there is there is
that that's just that's just the fact
and
even if you take boxing you're going to
say like boxing is not the same thing
yes there's a difference between the
weight of the gloves in women and
man there is there's a difference yeah
the weight of the difference is misogyny
we can't have this conversation with
these people especially most of people
that we're trying to have this
conversation with
they're not people that do sports that's
what do you do sports yeah then
that's what's happening no no you don't
you don't do sports then i shouldn't
talk to you about it yeah
what sucks about this is not the fact
that um bmb makes less money
what sucks about this is that we can't
discuss this without walking on
eggshells
in a professional settings where we're
supposed to talk about
our unfiltered opinions we can't talk
about this no
it's not like you would say hey um maybe
have them run around
underwear and basically with their bras
and their taste buds like i could
understand if you felt offended by that
but all he said is lower than that so
that there could be more okay because
let's say
what is one of the best things that we
love to see in the nba someone getting
posterized well how are you going to
poster somebody
in the wnba if a lot of you can't dunk
on the nets
easel you'll post right now when people
get post rice
you know what that means right yeah
they're getting a punch
someone abandons nuts is it someone's
face while he dunks
tea bags feel me those are moments it's
mo yeah and the crowd goes crazy and
everyone has that
it's it's a it's part of the game i
don't know it just sucks
this isn't about sports it's about the
fact that men and women
can't talk about her differences without
seeming uh
misogynist or whatever men and women
can't talk about our difference without
walking on any shelves
and it's funny this happened on espn the
same place where lavar ball
yeah if he caught himself because okay
no that's gonna look
that's gonna look sus yeah that's um
looking stupid
that's what i said i'm setting on you so
this is stupid it's really yeah you
can't have a conversation
whatever nothing you can't it's the is
dumb that's all i got
that's all there is to it that's it for
today's video tell us what you guys
thought
hey are you mad
[Music]